nowadays when you go to a funeral it's  called a celebration of life we do  things weird and we're gonna keep doing  them weird okay I'm not celebrating I  think we need to mourn a little bit  before we start celebrating okay there  we go finally  yeah okay new people are not in charge  anymore  I was inconsolable as much as you want  to prepare for it this has been a  two-year journey it's I was at the first  marathon I was at the second marathon  and here we are at the third and final  marathon called by Hawaiian friends and  the ladies gonna come tomorrow and plan  the Hawaii think for us this is very  fresh she's just passed away not 12  hours ago I think that we have to just  let this settle in on people this has to  be the way she wanted it it has to be  the way she wanted it so we got to get  some sleep cuz none of us have had any  anything else  Leslie she's emotionally drained I think  yeah I don't think my tear ducts have  any tears left